all right we're not even gonna waste too
much time with me and Joey being on here
you know what it means it means
overwatch yeah I can't show them that
all right here we go
we were kind of in oozing us about what
we're seeing that's a you want that I
would say all right that that I on ask
in their winter wonderland
so obviously new skins as well oh you
know what I didn't oh I did sweet okay I
almost I screwed up Joey cuz we were
speeding up so fast but new skins
obviously and there's a new mode so
we'll check out we got boxes we'll
probably play a match first or check out
the gallery that's what we always do we
got it we got to do the checking out the
gallery oh [ __ ] I gotta get chat up man
it's been a long day and it's only been
the beginning of the spoilers - oh God
so I was pretty sick
yeah even the gun yeah the feet Talon
feet and the guns got like a little owl
head on there like I would assume that's
a yeah right there on the side of it
there that's pretty awesome
good go through everyone he hasn't
gotten one in a while
no he's Gangi didn't get one Oh Hans oh
here
Oh casual oh no oh why put the dragon on
his butt man like put it on the back of
his jacket
oh no no filthy casual Oh Jung curette
Oh what how does that make sense I mean
it's awesome
no but did um well because in in
December in Australia that's that means
oh yeah we got to play by the rules here
all right we haven't looked at the like
victory stuff or any of those but well
let's get through the skins
since we don't know although I think I
saw to your Bjorn one you're just really
you skipped Farah Fatih I don't think
she has one though
briny was it the only only the four that
were in the in the intro screen no there
wasn't
oh sure oh yeah my boys back there is it
anchor a hook though he's a fishing man
he's a fishing man so it's more like a
fishing hook soldier Alpine 76 oh it
kind of gives me like some Zarya feels
yeah for whatever reason going full side
cyborg you so far Hanzo has been my
biggest disappointment I'm not hello hey
there user name yeah so winter
wonderland updates event is out that
one's pretty cool it looks really I
don't know if you need to go blue skin
though well it reminds me of like far as
a Halloween one there's new mode new
skins probably new emotes and you
[Music]
victory highlights there's not that many
then huh or maybe it's because we
haven't looked at epics either but I
mean I'm just going by the we're just
going by the winter wandering oh this is
from last year no Nutcracker no new
Nutcracker I guess Nutcracker was too
good yep alright so yeah you can
download that if you want we're gonna
play the new Yeti Hunter you go so
you're explaining to me that this is
kind of like evolved in a way where you
have five maze chasing after Winston
Yeti Winston who is trying to find some
like like meat yes as if the Yeti eats
for meat it's time to realize oh he must
ravage or go berserk mode and then
probably just like owns you like
one shot so you can prefer Oh we'll play
one each and then we're gonna open up
some hot blue boxes build the hype so to
speak
thank you for everyone tuning in on the
YouTube twitch Twitter and GameSpot's if
you guys have questions for comments hit
me up hit Joey up
we haven't is our first time trying oh
look at this why wouldn't they all just
go ice block mode oh that's a go catch
that Yeti I'm a Mimi we all have the
okay oh maybe look for the meat and then
he has to go to that meat like I think
there's one underneath yeah yes I was
like now you can camp it where is it oh
oh yeah like oh he ate that piece of
meat too oh that's very smart actually
remember that for later oh we got a
barrier to eat that meat you got to find
more meat I think I'll lead to all these
guys peace where'd he go
I don't know but he's about to go savage
on you oh here you go yeah you can't let
the Yeti out oh he's oh wow jump hella
far get that last meeting
Wow the cooldown really low
I'm guessing he has more life - more
meat oh the meat laughing oh no don't
don't say anything
dude you're gonna have to one me 1v1 him
well they still respond do they yeah
really I think yes and I have to eat
again
now he has to eat again yeah you have to
kill all oh oh that seems kind of unfair
but I guess you could revive and evolve
so so is he supposed to kill all of you
in one go I think so
oh okay the old is a trap it looks like
needs a double ice wall
oh no oh no oh you want oh I think he if
he eats twice
oh if he eats twice no but then he did
eat twice well maybe if he kills like a
certain amount of neighs yeah okay
that's pretty fun he seems to have ESP
500l which seems that it's 500 you guys
barely frozen I know like also if you
guys didn't know we are currently going
through our best of the year 2017
GameSpot's top 10 games we've done
reveals for 10 and 9 we will be doing 8
7 6 5 & 4 in the next couple days and
then kind of getting into our final day
where we'll reveal 3 2 & 1
we revealed 10 which is near automata
and today number 9 was what remains of
Edith pinch and yeah we're gonna keep
going oh where the Yeti is like this I
like this it kind of I guess it kind of
did that in overall two but it like
clearly tells you where it is
feel like you should have to search for
it you know like all right it's the
first one oh no they're all there man
you wanna yeah
no I don't think you want to do that oh
my god keep jumping you're not okay yeah
powers look at how fast you're you came
up yeah eat that meat come on oh these
guys know what to do so this is how you
do it
trap oh oh they tried to put the trap
down
going up and over I see it yeah I'm
phone oh you gotta eat clearly the other
Yeti has played yes so that's how you
see that trap in like you think it's
like junk rat crap it has to be which is
the best skin now probably say honest is
probably looks the best I think out of
all the new like Legendary's I think on
is probably looks the best personally
what do you think oh yeah I would say
well actually robodog's actually looks
really cool to look at again ice
fishermen
let's go yeah so the good news too is
like you can get the skins from last
year's event to you wait yeah you can
like how they give you a practice mode
than like just take it away hey how come
some of those knees have a different
color of s I think we're all the same
right feel like YouTube chat is not
coming through here oh you know what I
screwed this up guys we're gonna fix
that for myself oh I'm sorry I've been
missing some chat chats good though I
don't know if it's on ps4 or Xbox one
yet you can try restarting it it did
leave us a notes in a PC that it was
like doing an update at eleven so I'm
sure it'll slowly come out for you guys
as well so just be patient I apologize
and I'll be able to see you I'm sorry I
apologize to all the people that I were
chatting that I travel
oh my God look how big that trap huge
but he somehow escaped you saw what the
other guys did right he's blocked out
the wall he's like you're not coming in
here
always crap
oh you're by yourself one more life
overwatch on Xbox one says it's under
meaning okay so that's probably good
sign if it is under maintenance that it
it's almost gonna be out come on guys
should be trap coming up
he hasn't even eaten yet yeah but he did
bashing get a skin open so yeah there
might only was there four or five five
five no legendary skin
oh no four was it for Ponzo soldier road
honking oh and junk rat it's all Brooke
it's alright yeah six there are six
legendary skins I didn't know I don't
know if we checked the epics but I'm not
sure about that hands of skin says
Matthew Johnston yeah I agree I'm not a
not a fan of that casual Hanzo the
casual mana and Roadhog are the best
ones yeah probably I agree Jamie be 100
percent I play road hog so yeah that
road hog might be a must must acquire
but I don't have that gold so I don't
know maybe we'll play a couple games
just to try to get the try to get that
home winter loop box all right so the
the meat spawns in different spots each
time but you know roast you almost want
him to go in there so that you guys are
all blocking what the
Oh need to be a little more careful
those wives can go pretty quick
so you know what he could still do a lot
of damage like that if you guys are are
aren't all freezing him at the time
dashing has a legendary one says nerf
this okay we'll check it I don't think
we saw unless we skipped him on accident
in like kanji or something King Nokia
for you I thanks for the update yeah AI
keep me updated if you're trying to get
on those console platforms you want me
to try restarting trying to get those
those updates a lot of stuff out today
though Joey as I was telling you when
you're holding about the winter
wonderland yeah got GTA 5 heists new
heists are out you got resident evil
both DLCs are out we might even scream
that later if we have time we got
trapped oh my god oh there - slap-ass
well check out Bert bastions later if
you can't do it yet right
what can check begins our time I can
leave the game after kuipers I think you
just I keep going
plenty of players yeah we'll play a few
more and then Joey will open his loot
boxes his christmas loot boxes yep and
as a dragon games says which is
confirming what you said Joey junk rat
has a summer skin since it's in
Australia summer you prefer again I
always liked being the monster more in
evolved but I feel like it was a little
bit more favored to the monster than it
was the hunters the hunters had to do a
lot more work to win that game I know I
always thought it was worth fun playing
the beast cuz you get to just like
rampage and kill everyone
go check Bastion yeah do we get trolled
oh no it's right here it was all the way
thanks guys Piko Oh big
oh no that's you you do love that meet
God please I see him great start Joey
leave me alone let me jump okay thank
you
Hey damn dude that's so much ground you
just covered that I don't feel like they
can turn I know especially if you go
certain ways okay just get the meat and
then you okay so yeah so the goal for
them is try to block you as you're
jumping yeah this is exactly how we've
always you just want to level up your
monster feel like a really high level
and then mess with them because it's
like so hard for them to deal with you
and your
fifteen seconds not gonna kill anyone
what happened this camp
run now although seconds so cool down to
your balls man
don't want to do this the traditional
way yeah don't know where the meat is
you got to find the meat oh you're right
back into it huh no one that was well
the good news is if you can find a way
to eat you'll get some life back yeah
maybe Oh God soldier is definitely the
best I don't know about that Matthew
Carson I'm I think that uh
ana's and junk grabs are pretty darn
good they're just more unique I guess
like the soldier ones cool but it's not
doesn't feel like it has that flavor
well you're not getting my waiver of me
oh okay better than one yeah you
definitely don't want to fight too often
the other way I guess although the other
guy did that
how's it gonna play the game how you
killed one maid yo I got killed too
okay and then
yeah kill the one bit the fashion scene
was pretty good yeah there is anyone at
least the Roos
it's got a cool he's got a little beanie
and a different bird yeah and we'll open
some boxes so hopefully we get some good
ones so Auden got a new legendary skin
and junk I got a new legendary skin
soldier got a new legendaries getting
Bastian Sombra right summer a row dog
road hog I think that's six there's 700
seven because we didn't count fashion
early and we had six kids damn it Burt
alejandro
oh yeah Bonzo I forgot where is it I
didn't like it so I just don't talk
about it can we see them I'm freaking
consul yeah we can go back soon
Jefferson Garcia I mean if you scrub
back at the beginning of the video
you'll actually see a bunch of the skins
Bay's good I know he wants to joke
yeah freezing oh kappa oh lucky ducky
this guy one more meat and then he's
gonna go crazy
[Music]
Rizzy you got it man oh oh he's stuck
okay
I like the debate play there what did he
just fell that would be hilarious that's
something I would do probably jump and
falling did he where to go 25 minutes
still enough day says doko Bay yeah the
tough part about being on console is
that the updates for those are kind of
contingent on the console it's self
updating yeah times so it's not just
because it's out on pc thats gonna be
necessarily out on console too obviously
it'll be out today it's just a matter of
like the way that'll happen
so unfortunately apologies that you guys
can't play however happy that you guys
are oh he gave up oh we got trapped oh
he knew that the other thing I would
check too is if you don't see the update
on ps4 I would try like backing out of
here is for you know it's like resetting
it and then turning it back on
right should we open up some boxes I
think you go one more and we open some
boxes just in Santana I'm not I do
there is no legendary skin for doofus as
far as I know we still need to go check
through like emotes and the the
highlight intros Oh
oh here we go
I am Yeti no Gangi skin you don't play
sorry
where is PS board not sure it's not out
yet so well at least according to my
sources in chat how many boxes 50 one or
two you get one free one and we earned
one by playing this mode or winning in
this mode I like how age
wow that guy's bold I suppose a way to
ya heat panic ice block I think and then
realized oh wait too wide
am i near Devon oh you made it though
like they can shoot you oh there's meat
there oh ah
you're stuck in here oh so dead
rock rap crap - I guess maybe when
you're in berserk mode Oh slaughter
slaughtered them ate them for breakfast
lunch and dinner I'm getting the update
not on ps4 says Marcus lone wolf avoided
three traps in a row I don't so yeah you
didn't you did or jumped over that one I
jumped over that one - Wow / nut says
it's live good luck good luck good luck
eats dinner together here alright
alright let's do some loot boxes Yolo
swag and REE number one
and they say chivalry's day your
guardian angel
well candy cane you just a season also
if you aren't getting the download file
legendary already - definitely restart
your piece of work gold or Xbox real
gold please open the blue boxes we doing
that whoa what's a toast to boxes 100
it's a what oh she gets C Mon the digger
pretty much so it looks like a French
Bulldog saw this live streaming stuff
thanks Jay EMC joy to the world
dang - legend is back tag you're not
getting one for a while
Oh toasting that wine we classy mochi
looks like very Christmas Merry
Christmas see - sold I almost have trick
or treat you better than dupes I agree
but they come didn't they put that patch
in we're like to kind of get less tubes
yeah it's like less likely yeah Cole
lot of toasts like I as a smallest
teacup everyone gets a toast is this
just a loot box team no we actually
played the mode just now open with some
boxes now and then we'll play a couple
more matches obviously later worth of
battle mercy
I barely see that cutoff it's like wait
wait is he holding me check dude this uh
he walked to check emotes after the
boxes I was a Lucille from last year I
guess they didn't have a regular there
you go legendary family you didn't have
that though okay fine I'll take it
field dad man last time I got like three
old legendaries yeah
I also want play just like a regular
quickly because they changed Hani mourra
in King's row oh yeah after the snow
I can be nice get a good good strong
Legendary's at that battery an avalanche
oh it's got a little owl here yeah as I
said you got a different bird it's an
owl
average cool it's got different like
head yeah it's a new highlight see how
many way at 30 33 just burn through I
wish there was a mercy skin yeah
unfortunately not sorry
mediocre mediocre is it a different
puppy every time that's a good question
I said someone wrote in the actual do
they know like sorry is for last year
pity bear or sometimes was a robot RK
you're probably rolling with that
question but I'll ask you so our
characters in this game just for fashion
or is there more to the game there's
definitely a lot more layers to this
game then the skin the skins are just a
part of it
events themselves are free you can earn
loot boxes in the events with like the
weeklies and stuff like that you don't
have to spend any money it's all
aesthetics I guess I get that there's a
lot of hate for loot boxes out in the
wild but this isn't pay to win if you
don't care then it doesn't matter
thermos you get all the characters
regardless you know the paper fish just
call me Jason boy do I love slow
internet kill me please well if you're
doing a console so anyone in so protip
anyone that's doing ps4 console you
should put your ps4 in rest mode don't
just stare at it because rest mode will
make it go faster what skins are you
gonna use your gold on if you don't get
up pry ona ona or real like Road hogs
this time around so I might do that
you can't afford post yeah we guys play
the new brawl yeah we actually already
did francisco beta we're gonna probably
play like a few more matches and then
some just like quick play just to try to
see
you Hani mourra and Kings row with the
snow hopefully we got some of these
holiday skins so we can rock them in the
quick play he's Joey's been unlucky so
far he's only gotten bashed in until now
where he got sober oh I was gonna say on
him but I pretty cool be true so that
way there's no complaints so far there
you go loot box when you go inside yes a
pin you get one free one just for
playing the game and then if you win in
the brawl mode I would assume is either
Yeti or in the maze you get another loop
ah there's a bunch of different
objective stuff you can do weekly once a
question mark says Don's complex art
design yeah so it's kind of like evolve
if you've ever played evolved where you
have like five maze chasing one you
Winston Yeti who's trying to eat four
pieces of meat to them get like his salt
desert and it's kind of like whoever
kills whoever first there's only so many
lives for me
Winston can technically eat like most
like four pieces of meat multiple times
winding down a little bit yeah well you
know that it comes like this one on the
beach watching this in classes I like on
gaming Joe ooh that looks cool
don't get caught crafty gamer is this on
PTR no I'm sorry not crafty gamer
electronic game Eno get caught in class
I don't want to be the one that your
teacher says it's out on live servers
crafty gamer on console as well as PC
how do they have so many effing loot
boxes well I had Joey buy 50 for the
strings
so far two new ones I guess that's about
right though we usually get like three I
would say new ones and you've gotten two
old ones two new ones I think in a box
it gold yeah unfortunately RK we don't
take donations but I think our extra
life page is still up so if you want to
donate and donate to the kids Oh boom
road hog replaces my junking sons
monster that I've had for over a year
that's all they can ever take it off so
you're pretty good shape now now all you
have to do is just get the honest skin
which I highly doubt you're gonna get
but you never know maybe the luck will
be with you holy [ __ ] wall with road hog
we are a roll we are on a roll right now
place of my Halloween skin that's three
for four we've got four out of the seven
in the 50 or so boxes all right there's
no way you're getting another one right
trying to say that now I know I'm trying
to do the reverse reverse I know special
about it I know it's just like she's me
think like house like this no owner hair
that's it's not better than the eighties
one I want the event to see I - right
yeah well you can download it now
assuming
here at home or at least left your
console on yeah well yeah just finishing
up opening our little loot crate bundle
here and then I play like one or two
more of the got another one so only one
missing is honoring this oh and Hanzo
casual Hanzo yeah oh this thing looks
pretty sick like cyborg lost planet
style soldier all right what do you add
for just burning through don't even I
already knew that was gonna happen so
yeah pretty good I think casual Hanzo is
the worst looking skin by far so you
know you got like the salt and pepper or
the gray beard whatever we know what
you're gonna buy buy one so it's fine
when did the update start says red it
actually started on PC at about 11 a.m.
and then on console it seems like it was
about 10 or so minutes ago so probably
11:30 yep Francisco definitely wanted
put it in rest mode once you start the
update let's look a little Super Soaker
that it's like a nerf gun kind of del
pesci Mario in here and then the
soldiers 6 is why just why I think it's
pretty cool I think it's fine
I think the onna and road hog and char -
I love it
all right so what do you want to do now
ah should we go into arcade yeah let's
play one or two more of these Yeti
hunters and then we're gonna go and do
quick play but yeah enjoy m8 or enjoy
mate this is my first winter event I'm
so hype yea though events a pretty good
one I enjoyed the snowball fighting one
that was pretty interesting
there you go check the high wages I kind
of like this though
do you like this more there's no ball
more like this one I think this concept
is better cuz like it kind of changed
the way may played cuz like that
snowball has like yeah that weird arc
right and like just was like it was like
it was like almost like you're sniping
in like a like okay shouldn't say it's
just like sniping like in a battlefield
game but you had bullet like snowball
trauma snowball try is the new more good
yeah pretty entertaining like on in both
ways to me I still think it'd be more
fun to play as as Winston personally but
there is strategy here with the five
names to kind of jump what do you guys
do exactly at in squad what's your title
so Joey is a video producer and I'm
essentially a senior video game he ate
that meat hello Joey works on features
and gameplay and he's on live streams
right now then I mainly focus primarily
on
our live scenes and then our studio
stuff oh wow
fat backhand what are the five fingers
but what is a fist a to the face
to the maze and kind of like manage that
stuff so that's that's what we do here
okay last loop box and I got that honest
skin says and anime guy elite grats on
that skin that skin looks really cool
oh he's almost with like kind of like
talons for the feet and the owl as the
mask I'm pretty sure if Joey doesn't
just get it from wait what oh because
you ran alive ch da this should be live
for you
wish me luck that I get that Sombra Anna
scanning my first loot box
good luck dota ba Bay dude my one friend
has like the sickest look every time
like he gets a free just like loot box
from these events I swear to God I could
get this one yeah his first free one I
swear to God
50% of the time he gets a legendary I've
never gotten a legendary from it I'm PC
it's live yes it's live yes the xbox
updated also ups is tied the blogger
Thank You ty how long have you worked at
a game I'm gonna say GameSpot and
studying stop says wrapped rape dick
because it's we don't sell games here we
do we review games and preview games
Joey it's almost been what two years
were you have a year and a half for you
whereas I'm an old man I've been here
like six years or something that's a
long time does the new mode change games
now you're kind of locked into this skin
for man
then Yeti Winston has his own skin as
well waiting for Yeti
oh hang in there the best is when you're
like the Yeti and like you hear the main
must get junk rat skin says Marcus lone
wolf yeah we got really good it's a good
one yes the update is on ps4 Julianne
Van Beek hey I just need to ask how good
is the switch read if you like the
Nintendo switch or any sorry if you like
Legend of Zelda or like a really just
awesome fun open world game Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild is a great game
one switch same with a Super Mario
Odyssey just a fun game to play there
splatoon if you want a shooter solid
kind of like a variant on your
traditional shooter but very fun and we
think about and there's so many things
on switch there's a lot of back-back
like a lot of games that are making
their way on a switch like like yeah
skyrim make it on this wicked dude which
was not maybe not such a great switch
game but there's a bunch of things on
switch I would say that are worth your
while just definitely you know some of
those first party games with the
convention
and there's gonna be oh boy ran he's
like eff this I'm out so it feels like I
would say you almost don't want to trap
when he's frozen because you know he's
gonna jump right away and I guess
because he's lifted he's avoiding the
traps
team play I've already dropped the
honest game heart says a beam you saw
who saw grats on that you guys have
three lives time to hide you can't
Oh Oh
you always live I was like our plan was
your plan was brilliant until he said no
I'm surprised he didn't knock you off
first right I know what's up abode a
serie francisco beta almost done with
their update good good luck and have fun
uh I don't have too many opinions on
Sonic courses I didn't play it but Sonic
mania on the switch is also solid if
you're looking for another solid switch
game and that that one's $20 I think so
yeah you never played Sonic I think it's
a good like place to play a Sonic game
or a Sonic game to play rather and if
you did play Sonic games it's a good
kind of like nostalgia trip with some
good so we could basically to show or
anyone with that and he destroys the
trap Co pretty good
yeah a lot of people downloading the
update yeah have fun you need to go
super aggressive as Max one said I don't
think so actually I think the way I
would play the Yeti is I try to run as
often as possible you don't want to do
too many engagements specially if
there's like multiple maze I think you
can get away with fighting like one or
two if they're kind of like on their own
but you definitely want to just get that
get to the meat and and so you can go
berserk but I haven't played it myself
I just using my evolve strategies given
me is probably definitely like you don't
want to engage because once you get rose
you yeah and like they all start Miley
on top of you exactly it's all downhill
you want to make sure that there's not
five of them yeah three of them like one
or two like yeah you could probably deal
with that but like definitely just want
to kind of spread them out right I can
make them try to chase you and I guess
as the maze you should try to stay
together as much as possible and then
you know hopefully coordinate your traps
so that you can box them in
nice oh yeah see that's that's why I'm
talking about bring some guys what do
you oh my god oh he's ready to keep
boxing on the yeah what's key and should
I buy I got 3k credit I mean that's
really up to you like what do you want
to play for your main you know what
skins you like I think that's what you
really have to decide I mean 3,000 gold
he's obviously quite a bit so you know
make sure you're getting a good
investment on that that's why I'm saying
like I usually check for the 3,000 gold
I didn't really tried to pick one of my
main or one of the more unique looking
skin like Nutcracker was a really good
one that I couldn't pass up on anime
Reinhardt was too good for me to pass up
on same with like the Metal Gear
revengeance Genji
great what are you some of your personal
favorites favorites it's hard to think
great it yeah to go to your trap I
already used it run for your life
which mode is better the new one or the
old ones this PS madness I think we're
both in agreement that just like as a
mode I think we both enjoyed this one
more yeah where is the snowball one's
more of like you're almost like
competitive this ish PvP whereas this is
kind of Falls more in line with those
like the event modes well it's kind of
remember that the old one was a one-hit
ko so if you died within like first ten
seconds you're just sitting around
waiting the best ways we can pop that
all that you just like together alright
I get rekt to me it says I'm at school
everyone at school probably shouldn't be
watching but thank you don't get caught
either and if the teacher asks don't say
that I said that
oh this is good this is good this is
good
Oh someone should have boxed him in on
the other yeah and now box him in some
more cool down where to go technically
he can't get two more made cheese oh do
you think it okay so you hear the windup
of the trap yeah do you think it takes
until it's done winding up if you
actually take effect
what's up Pro Genji welcome back this
guy was
here I go Erica Mackenzie is in study
hall yeah that's fine
alright Francisco have fun you wanna do
a couple yeah let's see some quick place
the skis oh yeah show off the skins
hopefully we got some of those new maps
and then we'll probably call a couple
more more matches thank you guys all for
tuning in as we try out the winter
wonderland updates the second winter
wonderland this time with hunting the
Yeti as well as new skins and some new
watch you check that emote again yeah
for Arisa and see if she has more than
so we got a legendary which is the puppy
we're not sure if she opens no Gibraltar
so the other thing I want to say is of
course going through our best of the
year 2017 we did Aiden sorry 9 and 10
already and tomorrow at 10:00 a.m. we'll
be showing showcasing our eighth game
reveal so you guys should tune in to
that we'll be doing those in the
subsequent days seven six five four
leading up to our final three three two
one next Wednesday explain the Yeti game
again please sure
Narendra manga if you're the maze you
have five maze you're trying to hunt
down the Winston Yeti and you're trying
to kill him and he is five thousand
health as and you only have X amount of
lives to do it if you're Winston Yeti
you are trying to find pieces of meat to
eat so that you can essentially get your
ultimate which lets you kind of like go
berserk and do a lot of damage physical
damage and as the Yeti you're trying to
kill as many as you can until they're
out of lives and that's how you would so
basically Humpty
s kill kve asking what is your favorite
skin for me I personally will just have
to go road hog because I play road hog
what about you Joe I'm sorry to like the
the soldier one okay bug I was actually
pretty bold but soul I think junk rat
that's pretty good too because this I
don't even notice that your guy has like
likes no sandwich yeah there is no mercy
skin k-town now with this update no
tracers can either if you guys are
curious about skins if you scrub back to
the beginning of the video we go through
the all the skins we don't go through
all of the emotions
unfortunate that was really good yeah
hooking the tracer is so satisfying all
right careful careful
widows oh yeah prison oh you got the old
winter updates getting on rockin that
reindeer Oh who's got skin says Tim Zola
okay let me just tell you all the skins
there's road hog
there is Sombra there is Bastion there's
soldier there's Anna there's junk rat
there is Hans oh I believe that it's a
good be missing one that's seven
you really don't like that water Oh
I think I got it this doesn't what
snowing no not this time
Wow I think I guess I've helped my 79 oh
thank you got my ax
ps4 time left please help it's on ps4 if
you're not updating what I would do is
turn your ps4 off and turn it back on
get that reset and you should see that
update
as mentioned pro tip would be to leave
your ps4 in rest mode once you've
started the update as you finish the
updates
or very close
Oh some point on it so good daddy wins
almost every time I think that a good
crew amazed if you're doing a good job
with ice walls and stuff like that yeah
trapping him then I think I'll be fine
we've we've won as they like good much
good number of times I will say those
times that you guys want pretty handily
like I feel like the what call it was
not that good I knew I just I just went
straight through the pond just to thank
you
you almost got the pro cancel with cook
come here
never be the first one to hook that's
always turns out the Arctic fisherman is
better than the reindeer oh wait it said
it gave you the oh but he was like a
line of sight though remember in like
machine yeah plus ten but yet he brought
a little bit we wanted to show the skins
off and we want to try this those new
maps out because they got some snow snow
effects to him Kings row as well as
connemara but we didn't get that map
unfortunately
now haven't played road hog in a while
again pretty well with them
we're talking a pretty good
Oh cancel that hope though yeah it's
good you almost have all
Oh Shire thean show us on row we can do
some song play winter event as Winston
yeah we can do that - well end with that
guys roulette thank you guys all for
tuning in
alright sure we're gonna go play as the
Yeti as you yeah and then we'll really
Bob I'm not I think that the solver
seeing is okay this is freeze let's try
and find all the the emotes or the ones
I know you got this one yeah Winston or
Reinhard has one oh no hit the
highlights and Jana I think this was
near a snow point it's weird as Cthulhu
do I have change it back to Nutcracker
what why is he still all right we should
hopefully get Winston nope well it's
still waiting for players all right
we'll see
pounds are rocking the man but yeah I'm
not a I'm not a huge fan of the casual
Hanzo personally when it is what it is
hunter
yeah we'll keep trying to get the Eddie
will probably end with the Yeti bashing
John Bryson's yeah we couldn't show
those maybe Lauren cute has to meets
this guy's fast oh there is oh I think
he planned that to leave that there he
knows
so you get to armor when you get support
DS not doing a very good job
you didn't kill one man oh did you just
come alone
no so forth okay four lives oh my god
Mario cap 500 they effed up guess action
realities which makes me sad but they're
doing it so that everyone gets it this
kind of just makes me want to play
evolve again so diantha on gaming yeah
that game could have been good I just
don't think the hunters aspect of it was
as good as it needed to be or like there
was something there that I was oh my god
box him in
all wrong way caps are good no that was
last how do you leave trap you need to
get ultimate that's the trap and then
you need it to wind up yeah it takes
like three three or four seconds John
Carson you rip tired me and rip ducky
slaughter slaughter I think last for so
long it's 20 seconds yeah well that's
why I like I think you got to be
methodical about the meat she left it in
a area he knew that there'd be a lot of
junk Shack - yeah he jumped back - he's
like okay here's one here I'm gonna come
back to this central location cuz like
the meat doesn't spawn in the same place
every time there's like many spots there
yeah exactly is the shiney shinigami no
the shinigami there's a lot of ones in
there you've all been couraged the
monster - never engage until he is okay
yeah that's what I did I never fought
until I was level two or three just
because like why would you like why
would you fight it as a basic ass
monster when you could have the upper
hand just go hunt kill some stuff get
some get some buffs and level up evolve
essentially what's up Camilo campaka now
thanks for tuning in to the stream see
the meats gonna spawn right here it's
all good I don't mind when people ask
for shoutouts as long as uh for
respectful not spam it's why you guys
are here right
we appreciate you guys here we go see
okay
I don't know what these maids are doing
they must not know where the hell you
are are so that last ones there okay I
see him oh you're screwed no no oh they
were playing a can mouse game too - okay
so the other ones are okay there's one
there and then there's one oh no here he
comes
play of the game what do you do nine
more seconds of disabuse where is it
physically Oh God let me through
oh yeah oh no stay near the meat look at
this guy's planning out it oh [ __ ]
this has never happened oh wow okay so
did you lose help I don't know okay
now was it if I did it wasn't very good
you should actually just die from that
game over yeah
that would teach you to be like learn
you're missed from your mistakes what's
good fella's says Josh be pretty good
the updates from pretty good pretty
solid we're having a grand old time I
hope you guys are too happy you guys are
tuning in just trying to level up our
yeti here so that we can Joe he's
fighting with his basic gun he's not a
true Yeti he's really just
come on let me so you don't have to kill
one more maybe by the way yeah I need
meat you're like their baby need one
more piece Nessa if they come yet you
one by one
yeah so I guess see as no random lung
and says getting off the map is actually
helpful because you could just be like I
was screwed I'm gonna jump off your map
I'm curious you lost help from me I
don't I couldn't tell how was that oh so
you drop down to like 35 geo was like
3,000 so funny I will see if we can get
one more for you
this is so easy for Winston main uh
maybe I think that like I said I think
if the maze are pretty smart yeah and
they do a good job boxing them in if
they like predict your jumps I guess
yeah cuz like there was one time we're
like you were in that middle room
getting a piece of meat and they like
boxed you in like a couple times yeah
what's up like Mallis 88 game how do you
mind bitcoins I don't know rummage to
hard drives and like jump keeps and hope
that there is
my mistake was not buying a 10,000 or
like it I'm not actually buying one
Bitcoin for 10,000 but buying like a
little smidge man cryptocurrency is
pretty volatile night I have I've never
believed in it which is why I never got
into it to begin with
oh [ __ ] but uh like what of what a fool
though I was because you know I didn't
think it was gonna make it and it's
clearly something I don't think anyone
did I didn't think it'd be this big like
when I could have got it for like a
couple hundred I was like nah dude I
don't
all right all the meats behind you it
shows all three though so it looks like
there's five pieces of meat at any given
time so you can pretend you together
let me through let me through oh oh
there that's smart and you got traffic
oh so they put a piece to put them I
chopped down right at the meat which is
pie what you want to do I'm sorry goes
to Ellie's
all right so there's one meets akka
wakka if you're trying to look at skins
that we haven't shown yet what I would
say is oh because he's me this part
skins that we haven't showed off you
need to scrub back to the beginning of
the video player yeah see so these means
respect what they did is they basically
waited you out through the like first
phase right and then they're just like
alright now that we know where some of
the meat is - they just trapped every
year I mean so then they knew they were
gonna get some guaranteed damage I think
like the longer it goes the harder it
becomes for Winston baby yeah like all
the traps
hey I just I just didn't know just not
pay attention to those
yeah Shinigami says if the maze
coordinate this is definitely
advantageous with me as I can see that
team when are we gonna see read that to
gameplay who knows
whenever Rockstar decides they're ready
let's make this next one the lab do you
want to do anything else other than this
no you skip bash and we showed them
after the facts
all right you this is your last Winston
game then we will show off whatever
skins we need to at the end here and
then we'll call it a sorry there is
science
why oh yeah this centralized area seems
to be the most contentious okay this is
good actually
they're needy musk in now Oh see that
was smart
install last one oh this guy is smart to
see for all those that said that this
would be easy-peasy for Winston that is
not true
except for when he does this though
where are they at cranky you're just
gonna wait this out
may justifying evil force I'm back to my
base fine Oh God you show the soldiers
yeah will show all the skins that you
can get a second after this man we're
hopefully Joey's able to find the CR
this is this I feel like now they're
making the mistake
I heard them know they're trying to put
the traps down where you're at when I
feel like they're better off trapping
with me good now hon Yolo
I just can't them
I use anyone more were you at peace
oh is it for science though I just yeah
you're done dead no oh [ __ ] so we can
open that and then check that out what's
up creasing Chrissy I don't think
Winston can ever not get play the game
no Mae got it yeah it was when he they
killed it was very uneventful alright
let's go show the skins that you put
open the box and then woah yeah open the
box and then show the skins holiday we
do appreciate everyone tuning in though
legendary gold oh what's that
alright shows some of the skins in the
ERISA emote was that the only one you
might want you move I need to go look
through a ball right here you go there's
avalanche
Basti own Donna huh and this is I think
this one well that's a pretty good one
too that coursera one but this is snow
owl with the feathers here talons for
feet oh she just like a little knife on
the under backpack yeah yeah this one's
got a lot of detail going on man other
than my voice lines last year nothing
really for Doom fisty there Kenji has no
skins for sure you know that got the
toast yeah come pie
there's got casual man-bun
it's not really a man button it's just
like Thai double yeah where he has like
the dragon tattooed on his butt or like
the whatever his pants have it yeah -
this one's a good one bee track got the
rubber ducky got a suntan lotion even
though he's got a really bad leg tan
really bad cricket socks I assume it was
because of whatever he was wearing like
in his regular yeah like the sock here
zenyatta and Nerissa are the only ones
got it Thank You Tiffany rubber ducky
that's a pretty good one you got pretty
lucky man you got six out of seven in 50
boxes that's pretty insane actually and
you got like two old ones so that you
didn't have so the only Mo's are IRISA
so here's the legendary first it gets a
puppy oh it's the best a changer
let's see right update isn't out for me
says serial killer
I would restart your console if you're
on a console or close your battlenet app
and we open it
someone wanted to see the bow for honza
the weapons looks ok even more so for me
too just like that skin oh we didn't get
this kidney there but that was the only
one right yeah oh and Ana's there's only
two snipers always elusive see anyone
else
I think that's oh yeah soldiers Alpine
76
he's got a bale of tuna back here that
one's really good yeah that's by far my
favorite always like the different ways
are like coming up with giving them a
mask got the shark turns out the desk
owns a seen the updates done if you guys
are curious yeah
our maintenance is done rather alright
guys do those master work weapons some
bro and yeah awesome
cool that is it thank you guys all for
tuning in to the second winter
wonderland advantage is currently live
across the board if you want to check
that out go for it thank you so much
Joey for playing probably like this one
more than the last one I love this is I
feel like I'm actually participating it
instead of just watching people like do
better than me yeah yeah I like when
they can find ways to have modes that
are kind of just like more unique than
just you know what your traditional
shooter would be yeah
Duncan Stein stuff was cool I wanted
them to kind of evolve that a little bit
unfortunately they didn't this time
around but yeah it's cool to see so
check that out guys if you want to and
of course it's free you don't have to
pay or anything
get those loot boxes and hope to get
some of your favorite skins we might do
Resident Evil 7 still later today at
2:00 it'll probably be John Luke and I
might need to get someone in here
because I'm personally tired but maybe
you get so low it will see but yeah
remember best of the year tomorrow game
number 880 today was 9 be number eight
tomorrow 10:00 a.m. join us then we'd
greatly appreciate it thank you guys so
much see you
[Music]